[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera
cargo desde el parlamento europeo en
bruselas es un placer saludarles en el
programa de hoy hablamos de las vías que
se le abren ahora mismo la unión europea
para que otros países les suministren
gas y petróleo desde que ha empezado
alejarse de la dependencia de rusia
cambiará sus prioridades bruselas antes
de pasar al debate hacemos un repaso a
la situación actual y en qué escenarios
se encuentran los países europeos
desde que inició la guerra en ucrania la
unión europea anunció que empezara a
desvincularse lentamente de la
dependencia de gas y de petróleo ruso
una 'asignatura pendiente' desde 2014
cuando vladimir putin decidió invadir la
península de crimea la unión europea
necesita ahora más que nunca buscar
otros proveedores además de desplegar
más energías renovables
la comisión europea cerró un acuerdo con
eeuu para importar más gas natural
liquado también gas de qatar de israel
argelia y nigeria asimismo estudia a
hacerlo con venezuela después de que
varias compañías hubieran firmado un
acuerdo para exportar crudo del país
sudamericano a europa un paso importante
para la nación caribeña que hasta ahora
ha sufrido las consecuencias de las
sanciones impuestas por eeuu la invasión
de ucrania cambió por completo el mundo
y también las relaciones con los países
en los que europa tendrá que confiar a
partir de ahora si quiere desvincularse
definitivamente de moscú de momento una
gran mayoría de naciones europeas sigue
importando gas de rusia aunque los
países se comprometieron a reducir
tercios el suministro este mismo año y
para 2027 acabar por completo con su
dependencia
y para poner un poco de contexto y
entender a quién se enfrenta a europa en
materia energética hablamos con las
eurodiputadas si la riego del grupo de
la izquierda europea bienvenidas ir a
muchas gracias un placer estar con
vosotras un placer y con lina gálvez del
grupo socialdemócrata bienvenida
argelina muchas gracias muchas gracias a
las dos me gustaría empezar primero con
que la unión europea presentó
recientemente su plan para desconectarse
de la energía rusa su objetivo es
reducir y a este mismo año dos tercios
de la dependencia del gas y casi la
totalidad del petróleo gracias al último
paquete de sanciones se puede conseguir
es factible esto y no haber se puede
conseguir en tanto en cuanto bueno se
está trabajando ya apostando por las
energías renovables por mejorar las
interconexiones también por el alma por
el almacenamiento y también por buscar
decencia otros proveedores distintos que
suministren sobre todo el gas y el
petróleo pero obviamente es también
dependerá de la longitud
el tiempo que dure realmente el
conflicto porque a lo mejor en un corto
plazo pues sí que podemos
defendernos mejor de esa dependencia
avanzar en lo que llamamos autonomía
estratégica pero si se prolonga mucho
pues ya la cosa puede cambiar un poco
porque dependerá en gran medida de la
velocidad que sepamos darle a buscar
energías alternativas principalmente
energías renovables que por ahí es por
donde tiene que venir realmente la
solución y eso implicaría también bueno
pues cambiar de manera muy profunda
nuestra forma de producir no que no sea
tan dependiente de los combustibles
fósiles y eso pues evidentemente no es
tan fácil pero bueno hay distintas
distintos planos pero yo creo que en un
corto plazo sí que sí que sí que es
factible y luego habrá que ver también
de nuestra capacidad de
respuesta
y también de lo que dure o deje de durar
el conflicto será bueno yo creo que lo
apuntado bien yo creo que aquí el
problema es un problema de modelo en la
medida en la que europa aborde la
cuestión de su modelo que es una
cuestión estructural tendrá capacidad de
desconectarse del petróleo del gas claro
aquí la cuestión esencial o la cuestión
central además de la guerra es la
cuestión de la escasez de combustibles
fósiles y el fin de la era del petróleo
barato de la energía fósil barata esto
es el elemento central que tiene que
enfrentarse europa por tanto el problema
principal que tiene europa es su propio
modelo su propio modelo forjado después
de décadas de construirse en base o
supeditado a la cuestión de las energías
fósiles
lo que estamos ahora es en medio de una
crisis ecosocial de dimensiones enormes
y planetarias y lo que tiene que abordar
europa es y en ese contexto además han
agudizado por la desgracia de la guerra
de rusia invasión de rusia a ucrania si
quiere replantear y reformular su modelo
energético o sino por lo tanto el
principal enemigo de europa es la propia
europa es decir el principal problema la
principal cuestión tiene que ver con el
propio modelo energético europeo
y la complejidad que tiene rediseñar un
modelo energético que evidentemente es
complejo pero que necesita abordar sin
duda alguna la cuestión del cambio
estructural son las sanciones
energéticas realmente efectivas viendo
las consecuencias que está teniendo
ahora vemos como china e india están
aumentando además las importaciones
desde rusia será claro la cuestión es
que las sanciones a juzgar por
cómo está revalorizando ese el rublo
frente al dólar y frente al euro lo que
no tengo yo muy claro es que las
sanciones están siendo efectivas para el
fin que buscaban por lo tanto y lo que
se está viendo es un encarecimiento
general desde mi punto de vista tiene
que ver evidentemente con la guerra pero
tiene que ver también con la escasez
insistir mucho en esta cuestión y yo
creo que y también insistir un poco lo
que en lo que apuntaba al inah hace un
momento que es un problema global es un
problema estructural del conjunto de la
economía del mundo basada
fundamentalmente en este tipo de
combustibles y que habrá que abordar en
su complejidad pero vamos lo que lo que
sí se está viendo es como la escasez con
carácter anterior a la guerra ya estaba
generando una subida general de los
precios de los combustibles y de los
precios de la electricidad es decir esto
no es una novedad ahora la guerra
evidentemente ha agudizado el problema y
yo lo que es la sensación que tenemos es
que a juzgar por las cifras a juzgar por
las datos de la economía rusa lo que
estamos viendo es que las sanciones en
cualquier caso desde luego efectivas da
la sensación de que no están siendo no
por lo tanto aquí lo que hay que buscar
es una celda es acelerar el proceso del
cambio de modelo energético esto es una
exigencia sobre todo para europa que
está independiente de los combustibles
fósiles y planificar de una manera
estratégica todas las cuestiones que
dependen de la energía para salir lo
antes posible de este bucle porque si no
lo vamos a pasar muy mal en europa lo
vamos a pasar muy mal porque en las
sanciones están teniendo peor efecto en
nuestra población casi que en la
economía rusa yo creo que esto nos debe
llevar a una reflexión ya cambiar la
orientación de lo que está sucediendo
sí sin duda yo creo que están teniendo
un efecto muy grande en la población
europea porque la inflación de todas
formas la subida de precios sobre todo
la energía ya era anterior al conflicto
lo que ha hecho el conflicto es agudizar
la y es verdad que rusia está vendiendo
bueno pues su
fuga su petróleo a otro a otros países y
que por tanto no le está aceptando
tampoco lo sabemos tampoco conocemos muy
bien lo que le está pasando realmente a
la población rusa es verdad que tenemos
la revalorización del rublo es verdad
que sabemos que están teniendo otras
salidas para sus productos pero las
sanciones también implican por ejemplo
que no podemos exportar
más material tecnológico de alta calidad
o productos químicos que son muy
importantes para parte de su industria
de la que dependerá supongo muchísimas
personas y el empleo de muchísima gente
por tanto yo creo que también de nuevo
no conocemos muy bien los efectos que
está teniendo la población que
seguramente tampoco están siendo buenos
y que eso bueno pues puede tener también
un impacto en la longitud del conflicto
que yo creo de nuevo que también que
también es importante pero aquí lo que
estamos viendo y eso yo creo que lo
decía muy bien es ir a es es una
reorganización
global de bloques frente a un problema
muy serio que es el de la escasez de
bonos de combustibles fósiles al pico
del petróleo ya se llegó hace tiempo de
ruptura de las cadenas globales de
suministro que ya veníamos arrastrando
desde la cob y de ahí como un
reposicionamiento que además también y
en esto creo que también es importante
incidir también en un reposicionamiento
del reparto de rentas y ahí es donde va
a ser yo creo el corazón de león por de
llamarlos algunas formas donde bueno
dependiendo de la respuesta que demos
pues la población lo va a sufrir más o
menos porque la inflación no afecta a
todo el mundo por igual afecta muy
especialmente a las personas más
vulnerables y también a las clases
medias con ahorros y esto políticamente
para el sostenimiento de nuestra
democracia puede ser un problema del que
tenemos antecedentes históricos que no
voy a hablar y de los que no quiero ni
siquiera acordarme
antes decía y su referencia a las
energías renovables pero estamos viendo
que países bajos y alemania y han dicho
que aumentarán el uso de sus plantas de
carbón frente a la reducción que ahora
mismo tienen del gas cómo puede afectar
esto por ejemplo a los compromisos
climáticos shiralee no yo creo que lo
que no es aceptable bajo ningún concepto
es posponer lo que es una urgencia en
este momento y además es una cuestión de
sentido común nosotros nosotras
deberíamos estar en este momento
planificando las cosas para acelerar el
proceso de resiliencia y de adaptación
climática esto es lo que deberíamos
hacer cambiar nuestro modelo se puede
hacer perfectamente y tenemos la
oportunidad con los fondos europeos que
precisamente bien utilizados planteando
una reindustrialización sostenible en
europa y una aceleración del proceso
hacia las energías renovables hacia la
transición de renovables nos da una
oportunidad nos da una oportunidad en
términos de sostenimiento económico pero
también desde el punto de vista de la
viabilidad del planeta y de la de
cumplir con los objetivos de parís
completamente de acuerdo yo creo que la
urgencia climática no es una no es una
opción sea combatirla no no es una
opción tenemos que hacerlo sí o sí ahora
bien también es verdad que en este
cambio de modelo que tenemos que hacer
no es solamente una cuestión de los
gobiernos no es solamente una cuestión
de las industrias que sin duda también
es una cuestión de la forma de consumir
desde la propia ciudadanía que tiene que
aceptar como consumidores como
trabajadores ese modelo entonces en un
contexto tan complicado como el de ahora
siempre existe también el riesgo de que
haya un rechazo a ese a esos cambios
entonces yo creo que ahí es donde
tenemos que encontrar el buen equilibrio
obviamente a apostar ahora de nuevo por
el carbón por no lo mejor en español lo
tenemos un poquito mejor porque nuestro
mix energético es muchísimo mejor
estamos mejor situados con las
regasificadoras
para el almacenamiento de gas y bueno en
nuestras interconexiones no con el
restauró para que prácticamente no
existe error
no tanto nuestro es sino de otros
vecinos pero bueno
tenemos que también saber muy bien que
no se nos puede volver como un búmeran y
entonces hay que encontrar hay un
equilibrio y la verdad acto complicado
sí disculpa nos queda muy poco tiempo
pero quería preguntar ahora la unión
europea está buscando a otros
suministradores catar israel egipto
también venezuela se corre el riesgo de
anteponer intereses geoestratégicos
frente a otras cuestiones o creéis que
no es excluyente bueno yo creo que era
una materia pendiente europa ya tenía
relaciones comerciales y económicas con
países que vulneran los derechos humanos
arabia saudí- no es precisamente un
modelo de respeto a los derechos humanos
y relaciones con arabia saudí
lo que es una mala noticia es que en
lugar de reconsiderar este tipo de
cuestiones y exigir que se cumpla con
los derechos humanos se amplíen las
relaciones comerciales a más países que
están vulnerando los derechos humanos
nosotros pensamos que esto debería ser
una línea roja y sin duda
pero de nuevo si miramos el
eurobarómetro por ejemplo que acaba de
salir tenemos que la mayoría de la
población respalda las sanciones a
rusia pero también es extremadamente
importante poner los temas de pobreza de
naciones de 13-3 entonces de nuevo hay
un equilibrio pero totalmente son países
con los que no respetan los derechos
humanos entonces bueno parece que
miramos para otra parte también miramos
para otra parte con países dentro de la
unión europea con la vulneración de los
derechos humanos no los derechos de las
mujeres los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos por ejemplo en polonia
en hungría en la falta de respeto
también a las instituciones democráticas
y yo creo que es bueno que claro ese
realismo político muchas gracias se irá
a linas lamentablemente nos hemos
quedado sin tiempo a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy gracias por ver france24 en
español
[Música]